you don't often talk about it but let me
ask you on that topic about the blue
ring and the orbital Reef uh space
infrastructure projects what's your
vision for these so blue ring is a very
interesting spacecraft that is uh
designed to take up to 3,000 kilg of
payload up to uh geosynchronous orbit or
in lunar vicinity uh it has two
different kinds of propulsion it has
chemical propulsion and it has electric
propulsion and so it can you can be you
can use blue ring in a couple different
ways you can slowly move let's say up to
geosynchronous orbit using electric
propulsion that might take you know 100
days or 150 days depending on how much
mass you're carrying uh and then and
reserve your chemical propulsion so that
you can change orbits quickly in
geosynchronous orbit or you can use the
chemical propulsion first to to quickly
get up to geosynchronous and then use
your electrical propulsion to slowly
change your geosynchronous orbit blue
ring has um a couple of interesting
features it's a uh it provides a lot of
services to these payloads so the payLo
could be one large payload or it can be
a number of small payloads and it
provides thermal management it provides
electric power it provides uh compute um
provides Communications and so when you
design a payload for blue ring you don't
have it's you don't have to figure out
all of those things on your own so kind
of radiation tolerant compute is a
complicated thing to do and so we have a
an unusually large amount of radiation
tolerant compute on board blue ring and
you can your payload can just use that
when it needs to so it's a uh uh it's
sort of all these Services it's you know
it's it's like a set of apis it's a
little bit like Amazon web services but
for for space payloads that need to move
about in Earth vicinity or luna vicinity
uh a WSS space okay so uh so Compu in
space so you get you get a giant
chemical rocket to get a payload out or
and then you have these admins that show
up this Blu ring uh thing that manages
various things like compute exactly and
it can it can also provide
transportation and move you around to
different orbits including hum
you think no but blue ring is not
designed to move humans around um it's
designed to move payloads around so
we're also building a lunar lander uh
which is of course designed to to land
humans on the surface of the
Moon